[Music]
so there you have the first gameplay
footage of hawaii such a connection west
running to playstation 5
winokio and sexier building the sbr
[music]
wow who have you here
who you would like to spotlight some
the new all people have just  seen in
a game play capture and then help that
fleece welcome am de came
narrative direct interaction was a front
inside list links with home in large
connect all reviews verizon list is would seigneurs
a doctor future behind
global catastrophe people de van in
premiere tried
de der  no longer the dew minute species
giant
in a like machines to walking in
there i stream lead singer
the machines anti to not running in the
connect list and strange red light
aspirin cost line in your mobile own
device' strangle already live in ahoy
ar chiro is  the only one you can step
interest with you to china campanile we
have come to the ruins of those
worlds fine the technology within the
mass quest
ebola his throne beautiful or frame  erin
in romanian san francisco to find a
crucial choose technology
parent intro niche width of the gravel
taxi on the ten device dr visje
spiders letters chest sat the part-up
power override machine to rescue bernd for
centuries [ __ ] the first
simon's quest to go into  jackass
nu fiber of obstacles and sweet reverse
the runes of san francisco
de overcome them wie traffic of elo's
concrete new tools
using the focus knower you can highlight
spots dada life free timing anywhere in
the open world
to speak the podcast priming and king
get you quickly  to or trouble
[Music]
bring the shield louse too safely die
cent from great height or ze pas and to
do something for me wolf with the devil mask
still employed as long as you like and
take it ein te penne pasta land nvbs
machines of boost true  current confused
crimes and te muscles over line travel
and variety of machines candy
and us mt
earring get out of bed in a rise of
middleware keys strong  emphasis on
technix and player choice for close range
combat the muscle is an axel him looking
this range of combos there have the phone
users and effect sheets searcher serrien
i die special abilities one of which
can be used look back new my enemies
the muscle can  be charged upgrade high
ladies effect that can take down the van
de stad and emmy's wide array of the
firearms is quicky accessible via the
wat mobile sling shot with the risk
suffered the temporary steam engines
angry with arrow is this cathy palmer and
expo sweetspot
building of longeur  the fire spikes d'r
explo dan impact
slotboom the temporarily point enemies or
you can pick up weapons olaf van sheen's
the full game has many more you don't
weapons and each of them can be also know
the subject badge lost led and
always scared
the  play it be smart and creative and you
solve the bowl of options bf shown to
deal with a large variety of deadly
machine
such links in the sky plus further center
a toast online
step  was confused here of the siii mini
burgers that you will briefly slim by dr
al dangers and even more show van over
white byung ribbing
who of those scratch the surface of the
robot from is a lion of fight and in
many forms to go again  in the devilles
dan
siemens explore the open world to
uncover the secret to higher power
related to request
the steps blog this is right a wild
mystery show and gravel
answer journey to the connection was fix
one did not know and map
it's time  to wrap up new level
updates monastery lunch and ff when
adderall a call my beauty expert is the
for game
thank you for watching
[Music]